I hate it I hate it so much
yeah I have a pretty simple relationship
with Mayo and it's that I hate it I hate
mayonnaise like a spoonful of mayo has
the most disgusting consistency I can
think of it's not very appealing to me
it's very much like an eggy vinegary
gross mayonnaise is a mystery to me but
the funny thing is if you hide Mayo from
me
I can't tell there's me oh really in it
yeah that's that's a disgusting amount
of mayo see this is bacon there it is
there's something great and right next
to it is just a lard of lard I have to
take a bite you know all right here goes
it sort of disguises itself nicely so
like as much as I said I hate it before
and I do I still do this is passable I
wouldn't return this if I asked for no
mayo
I'd be like whatever bye who enjoys that
I don't understand how you enjoy a
mayonnaise people oh oh
well if it has mail in it fine just
don't like show me your cards too much
but meadow straight is it makes me want
to jump off a bridge oh not that bad not
that bad not bad as I thought
tangy
I'm out